oh god it's day I don't know what of
quarantine over a week I put makeup on
because we're gonna try to shoot some
videos today we're also now attempting
that's a toilet now today we've decided
that we're going to replace a toilet in
the house I don't think this is the best
idea or the best timing to do it but
we're going to do it this front bathroom
that we have is super cute
that's a greatest shower curtain it's
very Pinterest but this toilet doesn't
work very well and it leaks on to the
back corner you see all that gross so we
bought a new toilet and I watched a
YouTube tutorial about installing a
toilet and he feels confident in
installing of toilet so today we're
installing a toilet and a toilet it's
getting installed in our house during
the quarantine yeah this all makes sense
and this all is good and I'm confident
in every aspect of it if you guys are
bored with activities and you just feel
like you're only playing video games
just know there's a whole world of
installation projects that you can get
into confidently whoo eyelet toilet
toilet toilet toilet toilet toilet over
that toilets this is gonna be a [ __ ]
show what what you up to today I'm
tearing apart a gross toilet toilet
toilet toilet
have on camera because I already filmed
a little bit of it it's really up on a
big sensor bar all right you see all
that gross I'm just doing wall mm-hmm
work a little manly installation you
have the best contractor in the world
we're looking new the whole time there
is how can you stop when that thing's
overseeing the progress wait and find
out okay this is so romantic
the toilet has been moved out here
looking at it I think it make it like a
very cool chair out there but Elliot's
already vetoed me turning that into a
chair yeah let me turn it into a chair
I'm gonna turn it into a chair gross
toilet is gone the doctor scrubs in an
essential element in the toilet
installation process also we made
ourselves a cake yesterday because we
don't deserve it and why not the Gaga
fan I am Hal babe
[Music]
so strong so brave quick toilet hall we
got this one yeah well piece of a toilet
cool such man toilets half of a [ __ ]
awesome the other fun thing is I didn't
really do much research at all as to
whether this will fit the bathrooms
pretty small and narrow gonna be a fun
gamble I like to handle every mature
thing in my life like a scratch-off
ticket this is no exception
I'm feeling lucky okay we thought we
could keep all the old gross grout that
was at the bottom of the previous toilet
but we can't because this toilet is a
different size than that toilet this is
expected job Grady show proud person are
now doing our best to help the toilet
installation project and that is to
leave the house and go on a quick delvia
man home installation stuff some might
call it rough oh wow
grout has been cleaned to the best of
our ability Wow Wow
sexiest thing I've ever seen
[Music]
we're taking a break
toilets a bottom part some say the most
important part has been installed I like
to be optimistic and see that the toilet
bowl is half-full some might say it's
empty let's say break it's looking like
a toilet and confidence levels turn out
we have water we'll get at least one use
out of it Elian sits outside and reads
out on things about the toilet that he
doesn't try to meanwhile I made cheese
and crackers I'm contributing Elliot
tells me toilet is done everybody
welcome to bathroom Wow wait to get [ __ ]
oh my god goes away that comes back oh
god it's like a reliable parent you
really did it I'm proud of you great job
okay you want a second alone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after a long hard day of home
improvement we are now settling down
with some coffee and some scramble a jar
we I don't know
oh she spilled it I gotta go big things
big this is exciting news I just used
all my letters and I spelled toilet this
is the biggest thing that's happened
since we've been in quarantine okay
that's it for this video I hope you
enjoyed this I feel like we got
something done today it's watching
something on his phone he has put on his
yep there's a man that's done a hard
day's work thank you guys for watching
like this video subscribe all those fun
things and I think we're gonna post a
video on you tele 'its channel yeah yeah
you're not gonna believe it so go over
and watch that whenever it's up other
than that I don't know our toilet works
but we don't have toilet paper roll he's
using the bathroom right now oh good
he's washing his hands how did it go it
was good
[Laughter]